now obviously these movies are enormous
ly popular and III think that you and
and Dakota Johnson have a lot of fun
making them but also there are people
that love to make fun of the franchise
as you've heard I know that the movies
up for a Razzie this year three years
ago yeah three years in a row yeah and
and and you have actually said you would
like to attend yeah I mean you were
upset because you loved that the film
did if they invited me I'd be there like
they just don't I won't want and I
didn't even get invited I warned the
Raza
you won the Razzie and and you didn't
get invited the first movie I won worst
actor and I want Dakota and I work 1
worst on-screen couple right I
completely disagree with the Razzies but
I love that you have such a sense of
humor that you were willing to go you
wanted to go I mean yeah I mean I kind
of I'm so intrigued to see what it's all
about the whole organ or whatever you
know apparently you can just like pay
$90 and just become a member online
right I think you know an established
and an establishment that runs itself
like that sort of intrigues me well I I
know that you always wanted to have one
so the the Razzie sent over this is a
Razzies award they actually sent it over
and I know that you wanted to actually
have one well it's the latest thing
yeah water it's yours if you want it
I mean clearly a lot of work went into
that thing yeah that is that that kind
of sums up yeah yeah there are an awards
show for shitty awards that would
you